- [Seth] All right, welcome everybody.
Can everyone hear me okay?
- Yeah.
- Awesome. That's great.
So this is a code talk.
So I just wanna make
sure everyone realizes,
this is not a dark room to
hide and just look at slides.
This is interactive.
We're gonna start off with some questions
that we're gonna ask,
and we have a few slides
to go through for sure, but
the more questions you ask us,
the more we'll get out of it.
And I have a way to encourage that.
I've got stickers, so ask
a question, get a sticker.
That's the way this is gonna go today.
So we wanna get through,
we'll get through a little bit
of a setup here to set
up the conversation.
We're gonna talk about
performance obviously,
but after that, I really,
we want you to ask us questions, right?
That's the idea behind today.
- [Arthur] That's gonna
be more of a console talk
than a code talk, but.
- There you go.
- Rename it.
- We'll get there.
So, but before we dive into
it, I just want to get a sense
of who's in the room today.
Show of hands, if you ever looked
at your application's
performance, the metrics
around your application performance
and thought you're not really
sure why it's running as fast,
it should be running faster than it is.
All right, I see a few hands up.
For those of you that
didn't raise your hands,
I'm gonna say you're either
incredibly lucky or optimistic,
but we're gonna figure
out which one today.
So, okay, hands up again.
If you ever tried to optimize performance
by throwing more compute at the problem,
maybe a bigger instance, more cores,
more memory, lots of hands up for that.
- [Arthur] Thank you. That's
why the stock is so high.
(audience laughs)
- And then last question.
- Can you not record that one?
(all laughing)
- [Seth] Last question.
How many of you have heard
of terms like NUMA nodes,
cache lines, CPU affinity,
but honestly weren't quite
sure exactly how that
impacts your application performance?
Right? See a few hands for that.
Okay, I think you have all
come to the right place.
I think based on the show of hands,
you're in the right place here.
But there's a persistent
myth in our industry
that modern compilers and
cloud infrastructure have
abstracted away the need to
really understand hardware.
We can just write clean
code, deploy it to the cloud,
and magic happens.
But here's the thing,
and this is what we're
gonna explore today.
The difference between code that runs
and code that flies often comes down
to understanding the hardware
beneath these abstractions.
So let me paint you a picture.
Imagine you have two identical servers
running identical code,
processing identical workloads,
but one consistently performs
40% better than the other one.
No visible errors,
no obvious bottlenecks in
your tools, what's going on?
The answer might be as simple
as which CPU cores your threads landed on,
or how your data structures
align with cache lines.
So when you're pushing the
limit of what's possible,
when every millisecond of latency matters,
when you're trying to squeeze
every drop of performance out
of your infrastructure budget,
that's when understanding
these low level details
transforms from interesting
trivia into critical knowledge.
Today we're gonna pull back the curtain
and explore memory topology,
and explain why your RAM
isn't just one big pool.
We'll examine the art of hyperthreading,
and why sometimes using fewer cores
gives you better performance.
And more importantly, we'll talk about how
to actually measure performance
in a way that gives you more
than just pretty pictures.
And most importantly,
we're gonna learn how to
make informed decisions
on when these optimizations
matter and when they don't.
My name is Seth Fox.
I'm joined by Arthur
Petitpierre, let's dive in.
So I wanna talk for a second about how
to read the EC2 instance portfolio.
Over the years, we have lots of instances,
lots of instance families
to sort of dive into,
but there is kind of a decoder ring,
and that's the sticker you'll get.
It's gonna look a lot like this,
but sort of break this down for folks
so that we understand
what we're looking at.
So we have, you know, I've
highlighted three of our,
I call our workhorse, the C, Ms and Rs.
Those are compute optimized,
memory optimized, and
general purpose instances.
And what does that mean exactly?
It's basically a vCPU to RAM ratio.
And you can see the ratios up there,
and as you sort of move through those,
the vCPU to RAM ratio doubles
as you go up that stack.
Now this decoder,
we're gonna decode a
compute-based instance here,
but it'll work across
our instance families.
So if we look at this, we've
got a c8gn two extra large.
So what does that mean?
I've got a compute-based instance, right?
'Cause I know that, I see the c.
It's eighth generation, so
you can see where it fits
in the lineage of compute-based instances.
And then there's a couple of options
for this instance, g and n.
The g tells us this is
a Graviton instance,
so it's got a Graviton processor in it.
And n tells me this
instance has some difference
in networking, some
specialized networking.
So now we get into the number,
the 2xlarge is gonna tell
us how many vCPUs there are.
So everything doubles.
We start with 1 is medium, 2 is large,
4 is extra large, two
extra, yeah, four, yeah.
And then two extra large becomes eight.
So now I know I've got eight CPUs,
and because of that,
I've got 16 gigs of RAM,
because I know the ratio for those things.
So when I break this down,
this is an eighth generation
compute-based instance
with eight vCPUs, 16 gigs of RAM,
and the specialized networking is up
to 50 gigs of networking.
So while this is decoding at
one compute-based instance,
like I said, this will cover
our entire instance portfolio
as you're looking across that,
and you can use that to
break down different pieces
as you're making those instance choices.
- [Arthur] One last comment
before you go to the next one.
We mentioned in the table at
the top left, that C, M, and R,
or the, with the different
amount of memory, there's a myth
that we encounter extremely often
that dates back to fifth gen, which is
that the processors on the Cs might be
faster than the other ones.
The last time it was true was
for Intel fifth gen AWS instances.
Starting from gen six,
we have the exact same
processor on C, M, and Rs.
So if you're using an M6i,
you have the exact same
processor on a C6i,
and the exact same processor on an R6i.
Makes your life, as someone
analyzing performance, much, much easier.
It's also much, much easier
when you're using things
like Spot and you wanna diversify.
That's still the same processor.
And as much as possible we will try
to keep that a real thing
for the next generation.
So that's definitely true
for the seventh gen across the board.
So on the Graviton side,
a seven gen Graviton-based
instance, that's a Graviton3,
and that's the same one
for C7g, M7g, and R7g.
That's the exact same
thing on the AMD side.
That's the same Genoa-based
processor on AMD seventh gen.
And we've done that again with gen eight,
and we will do that again with gen nine.
I cannot promise that it's
gonna be the same for gen 15,
but for as long as we can do
that, we will try to do it.
And we tend also to make that broader.
So with the i instances, for example,
we've been using the same
processors as in C, M, and R.
Yes.
I'm not sure whether that
thing is on. Give it a try.
Yes, it's on.
- [Participant 1] Cool.
So you have AMD, Intel, and Graviton,
and even within Intel and AMD,
you have multiple families
and multiple, you know,
as I said, lineages.
So even within different CPU brands,
they are still the same performance?
- [Arthur] No, no. That
would be too simple.
- [Participant 1] Yeah,
that'll be too simple.
- [Arthur] So the processor
is exactly the same
within the same brand of processor.
So C8i, C,
sorry C8i, M8i, and R8i,
that's the same processor in
the same performance profile.
- Within the generation.
Now if you move from an Intel to an AMD,
they're gonna be super different.
If you move from an AMD to a Graviton,
they will be super different.
And I cannot tell you there's one
that's gonna be better at
everything compared to the other.
I can give you guidance, I
can tell you that, in general,
a Graviton processor will
be more cost effective,
but in some cases an AMD
processor will be more expensive
but will be faster,
and there will be other
combination with intel.
And there's never going,
well, it's gonna be hard
to have an easy answer to that question,
'cause they are optimized
for different things,
and so they behave differently.
And you will have, and
we will see that later,
you will have cases where,
oh, you will have plenty
of cores in the same memory domain
on a Graviton-based instance.
Whereas, AMD has done a
totally different type
of optimization, and you
have clusters of eight cores,
it will have a different
performance profile
when you access the
memory, will have an impact
on your applications.
- [Participant 2] So I
know within like vendors,
server chips, they have different SKUs,
and they have different
TDP and clock speeds,
but you're saying that these EC2 VMs,
like, the underlying hardware
is just a uniform SKU
across the board.
So there's no, like, I know
the lower core count tends
to have like higher boost
frequency, and that sort of thing.
But like, going lower core
count on these instance types
will never yield a higher performance
in like single-threaded
applications versus higher,
'cause the underlying hardware's uniform.
- [Arthur] Ah, as usual,
it won't be a straightforward answer,
but yes, a VM is a slice of a big server.
So when you run on an EC2 instance,
what you get is a slice of the big server.
Internally, by the way, we call
those big servers droplets,
because the cloud is made out of droplets.
And so that big droplet is gonna have
as many cores as the
biggest sizes in the family.
So if I take the example of a C8g 48xl,
that's gonna be a two socket server
with two Graviton4 processors,
each having 96 cores.
Now if you take a C8g.large,
that's a two vCPU
instance, that's one slice
of that two socket 192-core server.
So in a sense, no, it's not,
because you select small VMs
that you will get a higher frequency,
because they're taken as
slices of a bigger one.
And those bigger ones,
they have all the exact
same underlying processor.
- [Participant 2] And within a generation
and for a specific vendor,
those droplets are
homogenous across the entire.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- [Arthur] Now that being said,
we do have, if you really care
about super high frequency,
we do have special instance
types like the R7iz.
They're usually post fixed by Z,
and those have been
designed for high frequency.
So usually above four gigahertz.
We used to have M5zn,
that was one such instance, we had Z1d.
They tend to be instances
that we designed for things like EDA
where getting the highest
possible single thread performance
is very beneficial.
- [Seth] Cool. Go next slide.
- [Arthur] Yeah.
So talking about type,
families, and processors.
So we started talking a
little bit about that,
but basically the, what we
call the general purpose
regroups three different types.
The T, so the T, they are
the burstable instances.
So they are the only
type with the flex type
of instances in AWS to be over committed.
Meaning that on those
ones, we run more VMs
and we sell more vCPUs than
there are actual physical cores.
Great for costs, great when
you have an application
that has a limited
performance requirement,
but probably not good for anything
where you really care about performance.
M, we mentioned it.
So those ones are not over committed.
When I mean not over committed, it means
that every time you get,
let's say a two vCPU-based
instance, we've carved
for you two vCPU on that instance.
And we do it the right way, meaning
that those allocations are static.
The VMs, they are not floating around.
When you get allocated two cores,
you stay on those two cores.
So when the cache is warm,
it's gonna stay warm for you.
We never allocate anything
across the boundaries
of a NUMA node.
So you will never end
up on an AMD instance
with four cores on one
CCX, four cores on another.
It's always across the boundaries.
So if you have a VM with 16
cores in seventh gen AMD,
that's gonna span over two CCX,
and we'll dig that a little bit later.
Compute optimized, again, don't think
that, because the name
says compute optimized,
those processors are faster.
It just means that, if what
you care the most about is
having compute power,
and you don't care much
about having a lot of
memory, that's what you need.
Two gigabyte of memory per vCPU.
Memory optimized, again, doesn't mean
that the memory is faster, it
just means that you get more.
So on an R instance type,
you get eight gigabytes
of memory per core, that
can be much more than that.
Peaks at 16.
Z, well, there are few Z instances,
but it happens that, that Z
at eight gigabyte of memory.
Accelerated compute, that's
where you will get GPUs, FPGAs,
and various other types of accelerators
that we have introduced.
Storage optimized means
that you get local disks
that are physically inside the server
and not the virtual disks that you have.
Things like, like EBS.
And HPC optimized, those are
very special instance types
that are made out of the same hardware
but have a special ring fencing mechanism
for HPC application.
Flex instances, you will see
that some of the M and
the R instances exist
as a flex version, that's
exactly the same hardware
as the normal class
except we overcommit them,
and we load balance them
so that most of the time,
you will get 100% of the performance,
but you can go down to
80% of the performance
of the underlying hardware.
Super convenient when you
are not super, super critical
on the performance side, they're cheaper.
But if you want perfect reproducibility
on the performance side, then
probably they're not for you.
- [Seth] Any questions on
this? And there's a lot here.
- [Participant 3] Are they
similar to the T instances,
the way you used to use?
- [Arthur] They're better than the Ts
in the sense that you
don't have that mechanism
where you credit CPU cycles
and then you consume it,
and then you reach a stage
where you are out of credits,
and then we have that unlimited mode.
It's a more steady type of utilization.
So it's more predictable let's say.
- [Participant 3] Because
I've been thinking
about using the flex instances for things
like the staging environment
and the development environment
where, like, there's not a huge load.
- Hm, yep.
- Totally makes sense.
- Staging is a great,
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Seth] Staging is a
great place for that.
- [Participant 3] Okay, cool.
- [Arthur] Now if you really wanna
evaluate the maximum throughput
that you can get from an M,
don't take the M flex.
Sometimes you will get 100%,
sometimes you will get only 80%.
- I'll take %80.
- But for staging environment,
when it's mostly functional tests
that you're gonna do on them,
doesn't change anything.
And when you know that only getting 80%
of the max is sufficient for
you, that's also a great fit.
- [Participant 3] Yeah, okay, cool.
- [Arthur] And most of the time,
you will get more than 80%.
- [Participant 3] And did
it work the same interface
as like normal on demand?
- Exactly
- Right.
- [Arthur] Nothing changes, it's just
like, you name it whatever-flex.
And the biggest sizes are
not available as flex.
- [Participant 3] Exactly.
- Arthur, back here.
- Yep.
- [Participant 4] So on a T instance
with unlimited credit, do I
know when I'm being throttled
and I'm not getting the full 100%,
is that visible in any way?
- [Arthur] Ah, yes it is,
but to be honest nowadays,
don't use the T classes anymore.
Like, unless you really do
things that are noncritical.
Use the flex, they're a much,
much better proposition.
- [Participant 4] Got it. Thank you.
I guess kind of a similar
question for the flex instances,
is there a way to know kind of where
in that 80 to %100 your
workloads are getting?
- No.
- Okay.
So if you're being throttled-
- [Arthur] You have to
trust us. (chuckles)
- [Seth] There's a bottom though, right?
- Yeah.
- There is a bottom though.
- [Arthur] So what happens
behind the scene is
that we are load balancing those instances
with transparent migration.
So we have a pretty
efficient mechanism to ensure
that you're not all of a sudden
in a droplet that is so hot
that you're down to 60%.
We just transparently migrate things.
- [Participant 4] Gotcha, cool.
- [Arthur] And transparent
migration has been something
that AWS has been shy to talk about.
So we've been doing it
since quite a long time,
mostly for reliability purposes.
It's now in the EC2 FAQ,
but we were doing it long time
before it was in the FAQ.
We don't expose it to
customers in the sense
that you can't schedule the migration
of one of your instances.
But we use it a lot behind the scene,
and it's a really reliable mechanism.
- [Seth] I mean the way
to think about it is,
an instance is a completely
virtual construct, right?
It doesn't live in a place,
it lives in the cloud.
- [Arthur] Okay, let's talk a little bit
about what are the actual processors
that are on those different instance type,
and here I'm gonna mostly
focus on C, M, and R,
and anyway, that's probably
90% of what you're using.
So for those of you who are more familiar
with the code names of
the different vendors,
we often get the question
of, okay, what is
behind your fifth gen,
sixth gen, whatever?
So gen five, and another important thing
when you're doing performance comparison,
even though I would tell
you, like, use the latest,
'cause that would probably
be the right thing to do.
If you do comparison with
different processor types,
there's kind of a generation gap.
A Graviton gen six for
example would be comparable
to an Intel or AMD gen five,
and it's true across the board.
So gen six, that's comparable
to a Graviton gen seven.
Gen seven Intel and AMD, that's comparable
to a Graviton gen eight.
And well, for the rest of the gen nine,
Graviton is not yet there,
but that will come at some point.
So gen five on Intel and AMD.
Intel, we had Sky Lake and Cascade Lake.
That was a weird thing that
hopefully we won't do anymore.
We introduced it with Sky Lake,
and then we did a silent
refresh with Cascade Lake,
and it had almost the
same performance profile,
but in some cases the Cascade
Lake was a little faster.
So that was a little weird for customers.
We've not done it again.
Customer complained, and we listened.
AMD gen five was Rome,
and on the Graviton side,
gen six was Graviton2.
One recommendation I would have,
don't use those any longer
unless you're using them through Spot.
The price performance ratio
of those instances is no longer worth it.
So switch to things that
are more recent than that,
and you will get better performance.
Gen six Intel and AMD is
priced exactly the same way
as gen five, and it's faster.
Not extremely faster but it's faster.
So there's absolutely no good reason
unless there's no capacity available
to use gen five on Intel or AMD,
or to use a Graviton2
on the Graviton side.
Even gen six compared to what
we have released recently,
I would say, they start to be old.
Okay, we're cheaper than gen seven,
but in terms of price performance ratio,
you would be better off using
a gen seven or gen eight.
So on the Intel side, that's an Ice Lake.
On the AMD side, that's a Milan.
And on the Graviton side,
seven gen is Graviton3.
Now more recent, gen seven on
Intel is a Sapphire Rapids.
Gen seven on AMD is a
Genoa, great processor.
And on Graviton, that's a Graviton4.
And then the latest
that we have released
a couple of months ago,
we have a Granite Rapids on the Intel side
and we have a Turin on the AMD side.
And Graviton, well, it's easy
to guess, and that will come.
Couple of trends that we have
seen over the last years.
The number of cores
per socket is going up.
And that's true across the board.
You've seen that on Intel,
you've seen that on AMD,
you've seen that on Graviton,
and that won't stop.
That's gonna be true
for the next generation
of the various instance type.
The dollar per vCPU is also increasing.
The manufacturing technology,
the memory technology,
all of that is more expensive.
So the price on a per
vCPU basis has gone up.
That being said, the dollar per amount
of performance has decreased,
because the performance has increased.
So even though on a per vCPU
basis it's more expensive,
if your application actually
benefits from the performance
of the processor, you
get a better value prop.
The power consumption per unit
of work has also decreased.
So if you wanna be a
little bit less intensive
from a power consumption standpoint
and be a better planet citizen,
you'd better use the latest
generation of instances.
They're a little bit better in-
- [Seth] Does anybody
have sustainability goals
in an organization?
Show of hands.
Yeah, the Graviton and taking advantage
of latest processors will
help with a lot of that.
- [Arthur] Another trend that we've seen,
and we'll see how that will evolve, is
that some of our processors were
using simultaneous multithreading.
So the ability to use two
or more thread of execution
per physical core, some of ours do not.
And that has an impact on the performance
and how you measure the performance.
And we'll see that a little bit deeper
later in the presentation.
So couple of things.
Oh well, can we get that?
- Let me pause for questions.
What questions, where can we go next?
Everyone's gonna be quiet
today. It's the first day.
Everyone should be
excited and not tired yet.
Here we go, down in front.
- Okay, so a couple of things
about the virtualization stack.
- [Seth] Hang on, Arthur, we
got a question right here.
- [Participant 5] Are all of the families
that we've been discussing
available in Spot instances,
and where does the Sapphire
Rapids name come from?
- [Arthur] Ah, so they
were all available as Spot
right from the beginning.
So when we released Spot,
the Spot market is enabled,
but the question is not so
much, are they technically
available as Spot, as much
as, is the capacity sufficient
for a healthy Spot market?
'Cause when we release
and some of those things
are very successful,
start from the release,
and customers are massively moving
over to the new generations,
there might be very
little capacity for Spots.
So before you get a healthy Spot market,
usually it takes a couple of weeks.
More realistically a couple of month.
Though, I would say that in general,
the very early adopters of new generations
or the Spot customers who have core,
usually the Spot customers using Karpenter
are the very early adopters,
because when you use
an allocation mechanism
with Karpenter saying I
want everything starting
from generation X, the day we release
before any on demand customer has started
to use those instances,
boom, you're using it.
And the price is low and
the performance is great.
And then the on demand
customers started to switch,
and then the Spot market
kind of disappears
for a couple of weeks until
we launch enough capacity
that you start to have
a healthy Spot market.
Now about your second question,
the code names from Intel.
I think that most of the
code names are coming
from rivers and lakes
in the Washington state.
That used to be true for sure.
Nowadays, I don't know,
'cause I don't remember
whether there's a Sapphire
Rapids anywhere in Washington.
I moved like, I was in
Seattle until six months ago,
and I've never seen
any Sapphire Rapids so.
- [Seth] Our processor names,
a little bit more straightforward,
Graviton 1, 2, 3, 4.
Pretty easy to track and
you know where it came from.
You got another question here.
- [Participant 6] Real quick,
a reply to what you just said,
but why is Graviton2 generation five?
- [Seth] Ah, gosh.
(all laughing)
Great question.
- [Arthur] Because there was no Graviton
when we released the first generation
of EC2-based instances.
And don't ask me why the first generation
of Graviton-based instances was called A1,
because that was our first Arm processor.
And maybe at that time, we had the idea
that we would call the next one A2,
but we never did that.
And we had A1, which was
a porting the I call,
and then the next gen, we had C, M, and R,
that were C6g, and M6g and R6g.
Like honestly, I would not want
to be the one within the
EC2 product management team
having the responsibility
to name the instances,
'cause however you choose to do it,
you'll screw up at some point.
- [Participant 6] And then
my other question was,
so you said that as generations increase,
the price per vCPU goes up,
but the price per performance goes down.
How do you, is there any methodology
for like, evaluating
whether you'll save money
going to a new generation?
Like, if you're on a eight core workload,
you have to go down to four cores
in order to decrease your price, right?
- [Arthur] Hm, it depends.
If your application is really
running on a single instance,
yes, that would be a problem.
And there's the trick where
if the performance goes up,
'cause usually, you have
multiple parameters.
It's not only the performance of the CPU,
but it's also okay, I might
really need that amount
of memory for my workload,
and I also need that amount
of network for my workload.
So if network is really
not the bottleneck,
potentially you can go to, you are on a C,
you can go to an M with
half the number of cores,
and maybe that's a sweet
spot for your application.
But more often than that, you
might have a pool of servers,
a pool of web servers that
are serving a given workload,
and you are using, you
have a certain number
of requests that you have to serve
coming from your customers
and it's fluctuating.
And let's say that, on
average, you're using a hundred
of the servers.
Well if you have one that is faster,
now maybe, on average, you
will be using 80 of them.
So they are more expensive
on a per instance basis,
but you're using less of them,
and it doesn't need to be,
I need to be able to use half the size.
- [Seth] And don't worry, the idea is not
to necessarily worry about
the CPU load on your machines.
Worry about how much, what is
the API request per second?
What is the business measurement
of that instance, right?
The throughput of the instance.
And if that increase,
and you test it, right?
If that goes up,
then you're getting that
price performance metric.
- [Arthur] Now if you have
that single server, only one,
and there's no way you
can distribute that,
then you're right, you
get better performance,
but you pay more.
- [Participant 7] So I've got
a question about Spot markets
and like the health of them.
At what point do you guys start
tearing old server racks out?
I run a lot of bioinformatics workloads.
They need boxes and memory,
but they don't really care about speed.
I've got everything
going back to like M4s.
Is there a point where
like there's a deprecation,
stop using these, we're
gonna start tearing 'em out.
- [Arthur] So if you're running,
if you have things running on an M4,
it's probably no longer
running on M4 hardware.
It's now running on Xenon Nitro
where we emulate our previous generation
of virtualization system,
and we make you believe
that you're still running on an M4.
(audience laughs)
And it-
- It works.
And if you're in a company
where you had to validate that software
with that specific piece of hardware,
it still worked the same way.
But on our side, it's
probably no longer an M4.
So we try as much as possible
not to retire instances
for customers who need them.
So there are accounts where
you can still launch an M2,
but that's no longer a real M2.
Now from a price performance standpoint,
don't run on anything that old,
'cause it makes absolutely no sense
from a price performance standpoint.
There are other reasons to
do it, but otherwise, yeah,
I don't think we ever, well, we did,
but for some specific instances
like old GPU instances
where we can't emulate that,
and we could no longer
maintain the hardware,
and then we have retired those instances.
But in general, we do our best
to make them available
for as long as we can.
- Question back here.
- One question.
You mentioned about the price
for the latest instance type,
the price would be lower, right?
But one observation I made is,
when you're going with
the reserved instances,
I saw the older generation
are much cheaper.
- [Arthur] So I think what you mentioned
is very, very true for RDS
where they change their
pricing model for the RIs.
I don't think I've seen that for EC2.
- [Participant 8] My
experience, EC2 instance,
also I observed that.
- Okay, it's possible.
And we've been trying also
to shift customers away from
RIs, and to saving plans.
So what I mentioned in terms
of pricing was applying
specifically to on demand,
the way we've chosen
to price those long-term commitment
can be a little different.
- [Participant 8] So the second question,
all the instance types are like, one CPU,
like, memory and CPU are
strictly restricted, right?
Is there any plan for
AWS to, you know, change?
I can select the memory, CPU will be like,
let's say two memory,
could be four or eight.
- [Arthur] The same way as GCP does it.
Not that I would be aware.
- [Participant 8] Okay, thank you.
- [Arthur] But we offer
more diversity also.
It's like, it's the two
ways to handle that problem.
It's either you have a very small number,
and then you make that, you can go custom,
or you offer a lot of
different combinations.
And I believe that we
cover a very broad number
of possible combination.
If there's something that
is really, really missing,
please let your account team know.
We have a mechanism called PFRs
where we signal our teams that, well,
there might be that thing that is missing.
And if we feel like the demand
for that is big enough,
we might just do it.
- [Seth] My understanding is they may be
moving away from that, by the way.
So keep that in mind.
I can't confirm this.
They may be moving away from that,
that choose your own
instance configuration.
It's a challenge to
maintain for sure, right?
But with over 950 instances,
my hunch is you can
find something that meets your needs
within our existing portfolio.
- [Arthur] At the end of the
day, it's where we choose
to expose the complexity.
If we decide to expose
that level of flexibility,
it means that we add some complexity
in the way we carve the instances
on the physical hardware,
'cause the physical
hardware, well, is fixed.
So it's really where
we put the complexity.
So far we have chosen
to put the complexity
on you in some way where
we offer fixed sizes,
we offer plenty of them.
And you choose among those.
- I have two questions.
- Sure.
- [Participant 9] First
one, you mentioned,
socket count is to the maximum?
- [Arthur] No, on Intel-based
X class instances,
you have four sockets
and on U class that are very specific,
you can't get them on demand,
and they're mainly targeted for SAP,
you can get up to eight sockets.
- [Participant 9] The other question is
around hyperthreading, and if
you're gonna talk about it,
you can wait when you get there.
But I've always wondered about Intel
with hyperthreading
turned on, for example,
a simple example, two vCPU
with Intel hyperthreading turned on
and AMD which doesn't have
hyperthreading turned on.
- [Arthur] So I'm gonna talk
specifically about that,
and I will show you how to know.
- Thanks.
- Down here.
- [Participant 10] Hi,
without increasing the vCPUs
and moving on from the previous generation
to the new generation,
how come the performance
is getting better?
- [Arthur] How is the performance better
going from one gen to the next one?
- [Participant 10] Yeah.
- [Arthur] Oh that's, because
for all those vendors,
we're improving the way
those CPUs are designed.
So there are plenty of
ways you can do that.
Gen over gen, there's
usually bigger caches,
and that's true at, L1
has been pretty much fixed
on the latest generations,
but L2 has grown, L3 has grown.
You have massive L3 cache
on the latest generation
of Intel and AMD.
So that helps a lot when
dealing with memory accesses
and making your workloads usually faster.
And other area that can be improved is
changing the way the branch
predictor is working.
Same thing, plenty of applications
that are super sensitive
to how the CPU is able to
predict what is the next set
of branches that your
code is gonna go through.
So it's a combination.
The memory network has also improved,
becoming more scalable.
The memory latency has stayed
pretty much at the same level,
but the memory bandwidth
has increased massively.
On gen five intel,
if I remember well you
had four memory channels.
Latest generation has
eight memory channel.
Latest generation of AMD-based instances
has 12 memory channels.
By improving those different
areas in the processor,
you make them better and faster.
- [Participant 10] Okay,
let's say if I have,
if my application has any
performance issues instead
of just throwing more CPU
into there, you want me to,
it always helps or not?
- [Arthur] Giving more CPU to
an application is not always
going to make it faster.
'cause to benefit from
more vCPUs, you need
to have an application that
has some level of parallelism.
So if it is able to use multiple CPU,
that's gonna potentially make it faster,
up to a certain level,
'cause you never or almost never have 100%
of your application that
can be parallelized.
So there's probably
part of that application
that is still sequential,
and you won't be able
to accelerate that to the infinite.
One other thing that
I've forgot to mention
about how processors have improved,
they've also improved
in the way that we're,
in how many instructions
they can execute in parallel.
Many people have a mental
model of a processor
of at every cycle you do one thing.
But modern CPU, they do plenty
of things at every cycle.
They do memory loads and
stores, they do addition,
they do multiplication, and
you can, on some processor,
do up to six instructions per cycle.
And some applications are
built and optimized in a way
where they can only extract a
couple instructions per cycle
from a given processor.
And unless you
significantly optimize them,
they're actually under utilizing the CPU.
So there's not a straightforward
answer to your question.
It requires more analysis
and lower level optimization.
- Thank you.
- Okay, let's move on.
So one thing that, well, now most
of our instances are using
the latest generation
of our virtualization stack,
but when we moved from
fourth to fifth gen,
we've changed the way
we do virtualization.
We moved from Xen to Nitro.
This definitely has an
impact on the performance,
'cause we've uploaded a bunch
of the virtualization primitives
to dedicated hardware.
So it has lowered the noise
of the virtualization system.
So even, you could not
really do the comparison,
because we never exposed the
two virtualization system
on top of the same processor.
But there was a significant gain
when moving to the Nitro
virtualization stack.
It also reduced the
noisy neighborhood effect
that you could get from
the previous system
with almost no noisy
neighborhood problems with Nitro,
except at the memory bandwidth level.
There's another thing
that Nitro made possible,
which is bare metal instances,
because we've moved all the
virtualization primitives
outside of the instance.
So everything with regards
to network access to EBS,
and all of that, is uploaded.
So there's nothing that
we really need to do
at the hypervisor level
from a security standpoint.
So we can offer instances
as a metal option
where we remove the hypervisor
and you get full control over the CPU.
The drawback of that is we only offer them
as full instances, so they
do not come in small chunks.
But in some cases, if you need
to get full control over
the processor, it's possible
with the metal instances.
From a performance standpoint,
don't expect the metal
instances for normal workloads
to be faster.
The level of performance
penalty introduced
by the Nitro hypervisor
is extremely limited.
There's a little bit of an impact
for people having very,
very strong requirement
at the network level.
So people doing high
frequency trading for example,
you'll see a difference.
But for normal people doing
normal web application,
databases, there's absolutely
no point in going to metal
unless you need for other reasons
to run your own virtualization system.
But that becomes more of
a functional requirement
and not so much a performance requirement.
- [Seth] The hyperthreading
question came up,
maybe we talk about it here.
- There was a question?
- The question before
about hyperthreading,
you were gonna answer it?
This is the slide to talk about it.
- [Arthur] Yeah, yeah. Oh.
Well, the title of the
slides by the way is wrong.
So you had a question about
hyperthreading, I think.
I forgot, who asked? Yeah.
So that thing has changed quite a lot.
So before we introduced Graviton,
all our instances had
hyperthreading enabled.
So for each physical
core, you had two threads
mapped to a physical core.
Starting with Graviton,
we introduced instances
that were single threaded.
So each vCPU is mapped to a physical core.
Starting with AMD gen 7, AMD
is also without hyperthreading,
and that has a bunch of consequences
on the performance side.
So I can show you a quick demo on that.
Okay, so what I'm gonna do is,
here, I'm connected on a C7i,
so seventh gen Intel-based instances.
If we look at what we
have in /proc/cpuinfo,
that's a C7i large.
So that one exposes two vCPUs,
and those vCPUs are actually threads
of the same physical core.
So I'm gonna launch a
quick OpenSSL speed test,
actually I must have it here,
and I'm gonna do exactly the same
on a Graviton-based instance.
And that one also, same size,
so that's a large again,
but this time, we still have two vCPUs,
but each of those vCPUs
is a physical core.
So we got a certain level of
performance with that one.
So if we look at what we were able to do
in terms of signature per second,
we are roughly 39,000.
Now I'm gonna do a second
thing where I will do that,
but this time with two execution thread,
so OpenSSL has the ability to
parallelize what it is doing.
So it's actually using two
processes to do that now,
and we'll see what we will get from there.
And so we get a slightly
higher performance
at 42,000 signature per second.
But we don't double what we had.
On the Graviton side, where
we have one vCPU mapped
to one physical core, if
we do exactly the same.
So first what we can
observe is that in terms
of signature per second,
we were slightly slower
with a single thread of execution.
And now if we do it on
two thread of execution,
we have almost doubled,
not quite, but almost.
And I don't wanna use that
test to say Graviton4 is better
than Intel in that case, what
I wanna illustrate here is
that the SMT versus no SMT as
an influence on performance.
If you test your application
at low levels of loads,
what you'll see is actually
two different types of design.
Intel has big beefy cores,
and potentially they will give
you extremely good latency
at low levels of utilization.
On the Graviton side,
we have smaller cores,
but we have more of them
allowing us to map one vCPU
to one physical core.
At low levels of loads,
potentially we are not as
fast, however we scale higher.
So two different designs leading
to two different performance profile.
I'm not saying use one versus the other,
that's not the point, there
are plenty of other metrics.
And there are cases
where the Intel processors will be faster,
and there are cases
where the Graviton
processors will be faster.
But keep that in mind when
you're evaluating the performance
of those instances.
And the same would be
true with AMD processors.
AMD processors, it's a little different.
We have chosen,
because AMD had very high
core count processor,
we have chosen to expose them
as non SMT starting from gen seven.
They're more expensive
on a per vCPU basis.
But the performance you will extract,
if you are parallel enough,
and if you run them hot enough,
is gonna be extremely good.
- [Seth] And I think that's a key point
for this demo is this
was parallelized, right?
Like if the application
can't be parallelized,
it's not gonna be able to take advantage.
And that to going back to
Arthur's point earlier,
if that's a key distinction,
if the application could take advantage
of having those bigger,
larger cores is important.
- Yes.
- Question.
So this information about
hyperthreading, is that?
I'm pretty sure if I-
- [Seth] This will help
everyone else hear you.
- [Participant 11] Yeah,
so my question was,
so this information about
hyperthreading for example,
and probably CPU instructions
and other things,
I can probably find it on the internet,
probably there's a blog
post from AWS saying this,
is that exposed on any APIs that could-
- [Arthur] It's not exposed in APIs,
but the processor tells you.
- But then I'll have
to launch an EC2 to check it.
- Yes.
- If I have a-
- There are plenty
of things that the APIs are not exposing.
The API is not exposing the
amount of L1 and L2 and L3 cache
that you get on any instance.
The API is not exposing the NUMA topology.
The API is not giving you, I
don't know, the memory latency
or the theoretical memory bandwidth.
There's plenty of
characteristic of a processor
that the API is not giving you.
Or other examples, each of
those processors have options
in their instruction set.
So some generation of Intel
processors have the ability
to expose a 57-bit virtual address space.
Not all of them, some of them.
It's not in the EC2 API, if
you launch an EC2 instance,
you can check whether the
operating system has been able
to detect that specific feature.
But there's way more to a processor
than what we can really
realistically expose in the API.
- [Participant 11] Because
one of the possible use cases
would be, so I have quite a
few EKS clusters for example.
So if I could expose, I mean
I could create my own catalog,
I could, you know, do the homework
and get exactly the
instructions I care about
and all that kind of stuff.
But it could create no pulls
that would expose those
instructions as labels.
So I could schedule specific workloads
onto a specific set of-
- Yeah.
- You have to run this once
per processor, right?
It's not like you're
doing this indefinitely.
- [Participant 11] Per
processor, per family.
- [Seth] Well remember,
if it's a C8, M8, R8,
they're gonna have the same
processor in them, right?
So it's not that-
- Sure, but a 9 to 10,
I have to just do-
- Well, and when we refresh,
absolutely, you did.
Like, I'm not sure of any time yet,
if we've launched something new,
always test before you-
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Arthur] Well, I understand the request,
and I get it, but there's a question of,
to which depth do we wanna go there.
So far we have chosen to limit ourselves
to exposing the frequency,
exposing the CPU type,
and once you launch the instances,
you can get all those information,
because they are exposed
to the operating system.
But we don't make them
available as an API.
- [Participant 11] If it's a
non API, will it be on a blog?
We do have an internal discussion
on whether we wanna make,
we make it part of the documentation,
which could be a way to do it.
- [Seth] This came up
yesterday I think, right?
- [Arthur] The reality is that we have,
our team has that
documentation for ourselves.
- Correct.
- 'Cause we find it useful.
So yes, we could expose that.
- [Seth] What else? What else's questions?
Here we go.
- Can we go back
to the presentation please?
- Okay, right here, Arthur.
- Oh, sorry.
- [Participant 12] With
your demonstration,
it was a benchmarking on OpenSSL,
and you compared a-
- It's a terrible one.
Why have any conclusions from that?
- [Participant 12] You're
comparing a seventh generation
to an eighth generation Graviton.
- That was on purpose.
- Well, if you
tried the seventh generation Graviton,
I think you'd have probably
lost significantly.
- [Arthur] The two vCPU one, I would not.
The one vCPU, that would be even slower.
- Yes.
- But the two vCPU, no,
I would still win that with Graviton3.
- [Participant 12] Once
upon a time I tried
to migrate a load balancer to-
- [Arthur] But that was another problem.
- [Participant 12] Yes, it was.
- [Arthur] I know which one
you'll be talking about.
So the problem you probably have seen
with an SSL load balancer
was a Graviton2 problem.
Where on Graviton2 we made a mistake,
and we did not anticipate
that it would have that
kind of consequences.
And the problem was that
we did not anticipate
that RSA would be that
much slower on Graviton2
compared to intel-based instances.
The reason behind that
was that RSA uses a lot
of 64-bit integer multiplications,
and we had a single
64-bit integer multiplier
on the Graviton2 core.
And when running a SSL
connection, a TLS connection,
at the session establishment,
Graviton2 was much slower.
The AES part of an SSL
session was much faster
on Graviton2 compared to
Intel-based instances.
So if you had long connections,
nothing was visible,
and Graviton was doing great.
If you had short
connections, like let's say,
a gateway for a bunch of IoT devices,
or a gateway for an observability system
where you reestablish an SSL connection,
every time you send metrics,
Graviton2 was terrible.
We fixed that with Graviton3,
adding one multiplication unit
on the core, making Graviton3 much faster.
And then we also fixed partially,
we mitigated that on Graviton2
by optimizing RSA for Graviton2.
So within AWS LC, which is
a crypto library from AWS,
we have a much, much faster RSA
implementation on Graviton2.
- Excellent answer.
- That thing no longer exists,
and Graviton4 is doing great on crypto.
So we've closed that gap,
but that gap definitely
existed at the beginning
of the life of Graviton2.
- [Seth] Great question. Who
else, where should we go next?
We've got just under five minutes.
- [Arthur] Okay, well we have five minutes
to talk about memory topology then.
So earth isn't flat,
and it's very visible
on some AWS instances.
So you know what that thing is?
Well, actually that's mentioned. (laughs)
And so that's the memory
topology on a C7a,
and what it exposes is that
that processor is structured
with groups of eight cores.
They were called CCX,
compute core complex.
And those eight cores are
sharing a slice of L3 cache
and a connection to the memory die.
So when you run on an AMD-based instance
of that generation,
your application won't
see a flat topology.
If you have an application
thread that runs
on that first block and
accesses something in memory,
and that part of the memory
will stay warm in the cache,
if you try to access the same part
of the memory from the next CCX,
the information won't be on the cache.
And I've seen cases
of customers moving from four XLs.
So that would be, oh sorry, two XLs.
So that would be one
single slice to four XLs,
now you are spanning across two slices,
and seeing their application being slower,
because now, they were
across two memory domains
and if they were trying
to access the memory from one domain
where things have already been warmed up
from the other domain,
well, they had a cache miss,
had to replenish the cache first,
and that wasn't as fast
as what they expected.
And that one is on a 24 XL, on a 48 XL,
you would have another
level of non-uniformity,
because you would've a second socket,
and you would have an
even greater distance
between the cores on the first socket,
and the cores on the first socket,
and the memory associated
to those two sockets.
So when you deploy things on
AWS, pay attention to that.
The maximum sizes of our
instances tend to be two sockets.
So when going from, let's
say, in that generation
of instances, from 24
to 48, there are cases,
that may not be faster,
you will get more core,
you will get more memory.
But if your application doesn't
take into account the fact
that the memory is no
longer flat and uniform,
you might have weird surprises.
I had a customer a couple of weeks ago
who moved his database
from a 24 XL to a 48 XL
and the P 50 latency of
his database doubled,
because now memory was spread
across the two sockets, okay?
It had more memory, more vCPU,
but the database on average was slower.
Some requests were just the same speed,
the overall throughput was higher,
but the latency was definitely higher.
- [Seth] And this can also
be an issue with Kubernetes
as someone was talking about
using that before, right?
If your containers land on
different domains, right?
Now, all of a sudden,
on different sockets,
now the connectivity
between them is slower than
you might expect, right?
I see nodding heads, so that's something
to definitely be aware
of as you're looking at.
I know Kubernetes has got new features
becoming NUMA aware, right?
Something to look at as you're doing that.
So just something that can
become super important.
These are some of those
low level differences
that start to make a big
difference in your app.
- [Arthur] Yeah, my recommendation,
unless you know exactly what you're doing,
would be avoid the two socket sizes
on your Kubernetes cluster.
Well, if you know what
you're doing, then go do it.
But otherwise, stay
with the single socket.
Again well, we don't
expose that in the API.
- [Participant 13] But you
can do multiple sockets
if you were going in on
an old T socket host,
but you have a short,
like, a small on demand.
- Yes.
- All right, so I-
- [Participant 14] Does that
advice apply as strongly
to trying to keep it to
a single complex size?
- [Arthur] A lot less,
'cause the difference in terms of latency
and memory bandwidth between
two CCX is much, much lower
compared to between two sockets.
- [Seth] All right, and
we'll thank you, everybody.
We are out of time. Please
fill out your surveys.
And for those of you that want a sticker,
but didn't ask a question, come see me.
Happy to give 'em out.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.